on paper solo a star wars story wasn't
the worst idea but in practice the
project didn't really work out the han
solo star wars prequel was released in
may 2018 to a less than enthusiastic
reception becoming one of the worst
performing movies in the entire series
far from the billion dollar heights of
the force awakens solo brought in only
about 393 million at the global box
office a shockingly low sum for what
used to be the biggest movie franchise
in the world prior to the launch of solo
it was reported that disney was working
on other spin-offs focusing on different
characters from the franchise including
obi-wan kenobi and boba fett the boba
fett movie was even reported as having a
writer director attached in james
mangold who previously held the
well-received logan in 2017
but after solo crashed and burned those
plans seemed to have changed and at this
point we'd be surprised if they ever
went back to it if audiences cared so
little about solo it's hard to imagine
them getting excited for boba fett
imagine a movie that combined cowboys
ninjas and vikings starring chris pratt
in the lead role as the cowboy ninja
viking sounds fun enough right well it
wasn't meant to be based on a 2009
limited series from image comics cowboy
ninja viking was announced by universal
pitchers in 2017 and then delayed
indefinitely in august 2018 only a month
before production had been set to start
pratt was slated to play the main
character duncan a super soldier with a
personality disorder splitting his
identity into three distinct power sets
it was originally set for release in
june 2019 with a budget of around 65
million dollars but was reportedly
plagued by script issues which helped
lead to its collapse according to the
hollywood reporter rumors of the film's
impending shutdown flew around hollywood
for months meaning it wasn't too much of
a surprise that the movie didn't come
together even if it's disappointing for
fans of the comic
supernatural goth comic adaptation the
crow hit theaters in 1994 and it feels
like hollywood has been trying to remake
the movie ever since but every time it
starts to come together the project hits
a wall a revolving door of actors has
been attached or been rumored to be
attached to the role of undead avenger
eric draven which was first made popular
by brandon lee the list includes tom
hiddleston alexander skarsgard luke
evans jack houston and more and that's
not even getting into all of the
potential directors who have come and
gone production was finally set to begin
in 2015 before the bankruptcy of
production company relativity media shut
the project down by late 2016 financing
had reportedly been secured for another
attempt with jason momoa in the lead
role and the nuns coryn hardy in the
director's chair in march 2018 variety
reported that sony was setting a release
date for the crow for october 2019 but
just over two months later deadline
broke the news that momoa and hardy had
moved on not long after that sony took
the movie off its schedule
neil blomkamp made a huge impression in
2009 with his debut feature the sci-fi
parable district 9. while he's since
produced two more full-length movies
with elysium and chappie he also makes
short films with his company oat studio
in 2017 the company made a 27-minute
short called firebase set during the
vietnam war and focusing on some
american soldiers who experienced some
very freaky occurrences they were
monsters
in the shaving man
now they wouldn't die after the short
was released online it was announced
that the studio planned to adapt it into
a full-length feature if a crowdfunding
drive was successful enough long story
short it wasn't in april 2018 oates
studio tweeted the news that the longer
version of firebase was dead and that
all contributors would have their money
refunded as they wrote in their
sense-deleted message unfortunately we
didn't raise enough to do something
truly awesome we would rather over
deliver than create an average film we
thank the thousands of people who did
back us
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]